Prof: Okay,
so as you remember,
before we ended,
we were talking about Sachse
and how he explained everything
in more detail than people
wanted to hear about.
Okay?
And he knew exactly the story;
that you had chairs of
cyclohexane, and you had boat,
and you could interconvert them
by rotation about single bonds.
But it was only after the
Braggs had determined the X-ray
structure of diamond,
and Mohr, not equally
importantly but very
importantly,
had drawn clear pictures of it,
like this,
that people understood what
Sachse had been talking about
twenty-eight years earlier.
Okay?
Because if we look in the
middle there,
we see that chair form of
cyclohexane.
Okay?
We call it a chair.
People like to give sort of
silly, trivial names to things.
Scientists are probably sort of
geeks, actually;
but that's okay.
So there's a chair -- right?
-- that looks like this chair.
And that chair has a particular
property, which is you can fold
the back down and fold the legs
up.
Okay?
But you can do the same thing,
to do the ring flip,
as we call it,
in chair cyclohexane,
by counter-rotation of two
parallel bonds.
So take these two bonds there,
rotate it that way,
and there rotate that way;
counter-rotation, right?
One rotates clockwise,
the other counter-clockwise.
And you rotate group four,
at the bottom right,
so that it goes up.
Everybody see how the rotation
does that?
And I can do it with a model
here.
Right?
So I rotate around this bond
and this bond,
hold this part here,
and I rotate,
and it goes up.
Okay?
Now, so the product,
after rotating that up,
is a different conformation,
which we call boat cyclohexane,
or which people call boat
cyclohexane,
because it looks a little like
a boat.
Okay?
And people who got very
imaginative named various bonds
on this;
like the bowsprit,
or the flagpole.
But, in fact,
this isn't really a
conformation at all,
because it's not a minimum of
energy, it's a maximum of
energy.
You get lower energy -- this is
the boat -- you get lower energy
by twisting a little bit,
like that.
Right?
So the boat is actually not a
minimum of energy.
Usually we reserve the name
"conformation"
for isomers that are minima in
energy.
Right?
They can vibrate,
but they're at a minimum of
energy.
That's not true of the boat.
But the boat is what Sachse
made his picture of,
and it's easy to think about.
So we often talk about the
boat, even if it isn't true;
if it really wants to twist a
little bit.
We'll discuss that a little bit
more later, why it wants to
twist.
But anyhow, there's a boat.
Now, if you then did the same
trick to the blue bonds,
on the other side -- that is,
counter-rotate so those go in
and down,
rather than in and up,
as the red ones did on the left
--
it goes down like that.
And now you see what you have
is a chair where everything that
was up is down,
and everything that was down is
up.
Okay?
So we started with a boat here.
I can flip it like that to make
a capsized boat;
or a chair, start with a chair.
Flip it to make a capsized boat.
Flip it again and I have
another chair.
But notice what happened.
Here all these bonds that are
pointing vertical,
or down and vertical,
are black, and the others are
silver.
Right?
Everybody see that?
But after I do this,
they've changed;
the silver ones point up and
down, and the black ones point
out.
Right?
So that's changed the
environment.
That's interchanged the
environment of this one and this
one, of the black and the metal
one -- right?
-- by doing that so-called ring
flip.
Okay, now you should learn how
to draw chair cyclohexanes.
That's a very popular
discipline among organic
chemists, and it shows that you
understand what's going on with
the conformation,
if you draw it right.
And if you don't draw it right,
it shows that you don't
understand.
So let's see how -- people say,
"Oh, I'm not an artist.
I can't really draw it
right."
But if you understand it,
you can draw it right.
The only thing you have to be
capable of doing is drawing
things that are parallel to one
another.
That's not too big a challenge.
Okay, so notice that the
carbon-carbon bonds are parallel
in pairs.
Right?
So the red ones are parallel,
the blue ones are parallel,
and the green ones are
parallel.
Okay?
Now that means when you draw
the frame it looks like this,
so that opposite ones are
parallel to one another.
And now the only challenge is
to put the hydrogens on,
or whatever the substituents
are.
Right?
And for that purpose it's worth
knowing -- noticing the symmetry
of the ring.
Right?
There's a three-fold axis of
symmetry, vertical,
as they've drawn it here.
Right?
So you can rotate 120°,
a third of a circle around that
axis, and you can't tell that it
happened; it's symmetry.
Okay?
So notice that some of the
bonds are parallel;
are called axial because
they're parallel.
But some of them are parallel
up, and the intervening ones are
parallel down,
to keep the carbons looking
tetrahedral.
Okay, so six of the hydrogen
bonds are parallel to the axis
of symmetry.
So even if you drew the
six-membered ring in some
cockeyed direction,
so that its mean plane was like
this,
or like this,
still you can see where that
axis points and make the axial
bonds parallel to that axis.
Okay, now you have the problem
of drawing the last bond,
which completes the
tetrahedron.
Notice that the equatorial
bonds as they're called --
because it's sort of like the
equator, relative to the axis --
they're not strictly horizontal.
Right?
They go a little bit opposite
the way the red bond went on the
same carbon.
And notice in particular that
they're parallel to the
next-adjacent carbon-carbon
bonds, which are shown in blue
here.
Okay?
So they make a sort of an N,
or a Z, with the next adjacent
carbon-carbon bond.
Okay?
Now, what o'clock -- if we
start from that carbon at the
back left --
what direction,
starting from the carbon,
do I draw a line,
to draw the proper orientation
of the hydrogen,
at that carbon?
You know, one o'clock,
two o'clock,
three o'clock,
eight o'clock,
seven o'clock,
nine o'clock.
What o'clock?
Think about it a second,
and then I'll ask you.
Oh, we can do it like an
auction.
I'll go one,
two, three, four,
five, and you raise your hand
when I get the right one.
Okay, twelve o'clock?
one o'clock?
two o'clock?
three o'clock?
four o'clock?
five o'clock?
six o'clock?
seven o'clock?
eight o'clock?
nine o'clock?
ten o'clock?
eleven o'clock?
Okay, the answer is eight
o'clock.
Right?
Well how do I know that?
Because it's parallel to the
next-adjacent C-C bond;
there. Right?
See the Z?
So it's parallel to the
next-adjacent C-C bond.
Okay, now how about there,
what o'clock?
one o'clock?
two o'clock?
three o'clock?
four o'clock?
five o'clock? Okay.
It's about 1:30, right?
-- sort of like one o'clock --
because it's parallel to the
next-adjacent C-C bonds,
which are pointing
anti-parallel,
right?;
parallel, but in the opposite
direction from their nearest
carbon.
Okay, try here.
One o'clock?
two o'clock?
three o'clock?
four o'clock?
five o'clock?
Ah, you're getting better,
right?
About four o'clock;
3:30 maybe.
Okay, how about here?
One, o'clock?
two o'clock?
three o'clock?
Okay, two o'clock.
Okay, how about here?
One?
Two?
Three?
Ah, I got some votes for one.
Now I'm going to come back and
ask what's wrong with one
o'clock?
Okay?
There's what it is.
It's actually seven o'clock.
How is that related to one
o'clock?
It's anti-parallel, right?
If you did one o'clock,
it would have made a U with the
next-adjacent bond,
rather than an N or a Z.
Do you see that,
see where the mistake was?
Okay, so if you understand
this, if you understand that the
hydrogen is anti to the
next-adjacent C-C bond -- right?
-- then you won't draw it
wrong, you won't draw a U,
which would be eclipsed.
Right?
You'd draw it anti,
which makes a Z or an N.
Okay, so if you understand it,
you'll draw it.
So it wouldn't be surprising if
that were on some test sometime,
to draw a cyclohexane sometime.
Okay, now this got interesting
because in the 1940s and '50s,
synthetic organic chemists were
very interested in steroid
hormones;
in the '30s,
'40s and '50s.
Right?
And it turned out that you had
these two alcohols,
which were called β
and α.
And beta is the one that came
up, toward the viewer,
and alpha is the one that goes
back into the paper.
But of course,
that depends on how you drew
the molecule.
If you drew the molecule upside
down, it'd be just the opposite.
But synthetic organic chemists,
who were interested in this
kind of thing,
weren't bothered about this,
because they always drew it the
same way.
Right?
So they knew what they meant by
up and down.
But that's like names that
don't really tell you what the
--
don't allow a novice to know
what the structure is,
to talk α
and β.
People still talk about
α and β
substituents,
the ones that point out of the
paper and into the paper,
in steroids.
But you have to know the lore.
You have to know how people
always draw the rings,
in order to know what comes out
and what comes in.
So it's like cis and
trans,
a little bit,
not knowing what's cis
to what.
Baeyer, remember,
said it didn't make a
difference, because there was
only one cyclohexane carboxylic
acid.
Right?
Because if you had axial and
equatorial ones,
the rings could flip and they
would interconvert and it'd all
be the same.
Right?
So, but it's interesting that
the β and the
α isomers of these
alcohols have different
reactivity.
They are different.
Right?
They behave differently.
They don't interconvert. Right?
And you can see why that would
be so.
What's the relation between the
β and the
α?
Are they mirror images?
Are their environments
identical?
Enantiotopic?
Diastereotopic?
There's an easy way to
recognize this.
They exist at a chiral center,
because going around one carbon
and going around the other are
different paths;
they encounter different things
as you move along.
Right?
So it's a chiral center.
But there are other chiral
centers in the molecule.
And when you have two chiral
centers, then changing just one
doesn't give the mirror image.
It gives an epimer,
not an enantiomer.
So they are diastereotopic.
Right?
Now, for these kinds of
problems, Derek H.R. Barton
invented what was called
"conformational
analysis",
in 1950.
He was interested in these
steroid hormones,
as many people were.
Right?
So conventionally these
six-membered rings were labeled
A, B, C, and then the
five-membered ring D,
so people could know what they
were talking about.
Right?
And Barton redrew ring A.
And notice that the
β,
α is
configurationally
diastereotopic.
You'd have to break bonds to
make the α into
β.
So it doesn't surprise us that
they're different.
Right?
But let's look at just how
they're different.
So this is the picture,
from his paper in 1950,
that Barton drew to show that
ring A;
and the bracket there,
that I've drawn in,
shows where it would go on to
ring B.
I've truncated his picture.
Now I want to ask you a
question.
So β goes up,
relative to the mean plane of
the ring, and α
goes down.
And he labeled these things
e or p,
for equatorial -- that's what
we still call it,
as I told you,
the one that points more or
less in the plane of the ring.
And he called the others
p, for polar,
as if it were a globe and had
an axis, the pole.
But we call it now axial.
So that's changed since he
invented this.
But I think you're probably
sophisticated enough now,
having had this practice,
to recognize an error in what
he drew.
Do you see what's wrong with
his pictures?
Marty, what do you say?
Are the equatorial bonds,
do they make Z's with the
carbon frame?
That is, are they anti to the
next adjacent carbon-carbon
bond?
Take an equatorial one,
like this one here.
Is this carbon-carbon bond
anti-parallel,
at the correct o'clock,
relative to this bond?
Student:  It needs to be
more >.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  It needs to be
more like eleven-ish.
Prof: No,
this one, notice,
is exactly horizontal,
and this one is exactly
horizontal.
So they're perfectly anti.
Or take this one. Right?
Here's its bond,
and here's the next adjacent
C-C bond, one to ten.
And they're exactly
antiparallel.
Okay?
So that's anti too.
So the equatorial ones are fine.
How about the axial ones?
Do they look good?
Catherine, what do you say?
What does axial mean?
What's axial about it?
Maria?
Student:  The molecule
can be rotated around the axis.
Prof: Okay,
what direction does that axis
point,
that you can rotate that
six-membered ring around it and
get the same thing?
What o'clock does it point,
from the center of the ring?
Student:  So it should
point like eleven o'clock.
Prof: Yeah,
about eleven o'clock.
There are the sets of three
carbons that are related by
that, and the axis goes at about
eleven o'clock.
What does that mean Maria,
about the axial bonds?
Student:  That they
should also be pointing up.
Prof: They should be
parallel to that axial
direction.
Right?
So they really should be this
direction -- right?
-- parallel to that axis.
So the very guy who invented
it, in the very paper in which
he did the invention,
drew them wrong.
That's not too surprising.
Right?
But it's interesting to note.
So you don't have to feel bad
when you draw it wrong the first
few times.
By the time we get to an exam,
you'll know how to draw it
right;
better than Barton did,
when he published his paper.
Okay, he got the Nobel Prize,
in 1969, for development of the
concept of conformation and its
applications in chemistry.
So he didn't get the Nobel
Prize for drawing the axial
bonds wrong.
Right?
What he got the Nobel Prize was
for the application,
showing how important this was
in chemistry;
that those axial and equatorial
groups -- hydrogens in this
case;
but they could be other groups
-- have different chemistry.
Right?
And notice the date, 1950.
All these things about
stereochemistry were happening
within plus or minus a few years
of that.
We've already talked about
Bijvoet determining the absolute
configuration of tartaric acid;
Newman figuring out how to draw
his projections,
to show conformation;
the Cahn-Ingold-Prelog rules;
and, as we'll see shortly,
the idea of molecular
mechanics.
Okay?
Now, what made Baeyer say
everything was the same,
although he didn't know it,
was that the ring would flip,
interconverting axial and
equatorial,
as we just looked.
But can the ring -- if the ring
can flip in this one,
it would also interconvert
axial and equatorial -- but can
the ring flip?
That's the question.
So let's think a little bit
more about how the ring-flip
works.
Notice that during a ring-flip,
as in the top left there,
what's equatorial becomes
axial.
So you look on the top left,
there's an equatorial bond,
and in the right that becomes
an axial bond;
well actually you'd call it a
-- what is it?
-- flagpole, in the boat. Right?
But when you do the other flip
of the blue one,
that one that's purple is
there.
Right?
So the one that was equatorial
in the chair on the top left,
after a flip becomes axial.
And we already saw that here,
that the ones that are
equatorial become axial when you
do the double ring flip.
Okay?
Now, and by the same token,
the ones that are axial become
equatorial.
So if you start on the top left
with those two green ones,
which are anti to one another,
axial --
notice they point a little to
the right because the axis of --
the symmetry axis is not
straight up and down.
Right?
After the first part of the
flip to the boat looks like
that;
and the second part of the
flip, they become equatorial,
and gauche to one another,
where they were anti
originally.
Right?
So now if you have fused rings
-- that is,
two six-membered rings that
share a bond,
as on the bottom there -- those
two green ones can be part of
the second ring;
gauche to one another,
as all the carbons are around
the cyclohexane ring in its
chair form.
So they're gauche,
and that's fine.
But if you tried to flip it,
those two green ones,
with respect to the front ring,
would become axial,
as on the top left.
And if they pointed axial,
you couldn't possibly complete
the ring.
Right?
So here's two chairs,
here and here.
Now if I could try to flip this
one up -- I could flip this one
down probably;
there, down. Right?
So I got it almost into a boat.
But I can't even make it into a
boat, let alone flip the other
ring.
And the reason is that these
two are tying these two -- while
I'm trying to flip this one,
these two are holding this one
and won't let it go.
They can't become axial to one
another.
Right?
Just because the carbons can't
reach.
Okay, so in what's called --
decalin means decahydro,
ten hydrogens,
on naphthalene;
naphthalene is like benzene,
except two of them.
Right?
So this is decalin,
or ten hydrogens on
naphthalene.
And this one is called
trans-decalin.
Right?
These two hydrogens are trans
to one another.
And in that one,
I can't flip the rings.
If I had cis-decalin,
like this, then it's possible
to flip the rings;
which I could do like this.
Let's see.
Well ho, ho, ho.
I think I did it there.
Yeah, I did.
Okay.
So you can flip the ring if
it's cis,
but not if it's trans.
And the point is that you can't
take two equatorial things and
make them both axial in a ring,
because those carbons get too
far apart to be bridged by the
rest of the ring.
But if they're gauche to one
another, then they can be gauche
to one another on the other side
and it can flip.
It's fun to play.
You know, we used to require
people to buy models.
Now you can do things with
computers that make it that it's
probably not worth your money to
buy the models.
But it's still a lot of fun,
and you learn something with
your hands.
It's like when people have
trouble in elementary school
with arithmetic;
the teacher gives them
toothpicks to count with and so
on.
It's a higher level than that,
but it's the same thing;
you learn a lot with your hands.
So it's fun to play with these.
In fact, let me pass around
here simplified models that are
a chair.
But you can do this trick of
changing one into the other by
rotating.
And feeling it is fun. Right?
So that you have the
opportunity to feel it,
I'll pass these around.
There you go.
Okay, the ring flip is
impossible for
trans-decalin.
Okay, but so gauche because
gauche is okay within the second
ring of decalin,
but not anti.
Okay, so and you try with
models if you're skeptical.
If you want to come afterwards
and fiddle with the decalins,
you're free.
Okay now, nowadays people,
much more often,
encounter these things on
animations.
But this is a nice webpage that
we have permission to use in the
course;
I mean, you could use it on
your own anyhow,
on the net if you wanted to.
But it's a cautionary tale
because just because it looks
nice and works,
doesn't mean it gives the right
answers.
So let me show you what I mean.
Okay, so if you go to this
website, you can click there to
get it.
And it's a nice tutorial about
conformation.
So they show here,
for example,
ethane,
and if you click 'Play' --
let's see,
I think I've got it animated
here --
you can step from one position
to the next and see what the
shape looks like.
Not that ethane is so very
exciting, but you can see it go
down and up, as it goes from
eclipsed to staggered.
And you can click on a point
and the model will turn,
to show you what it's like.
I'll give an example of this
later.
And there's the staggered and
there's the eclipsed.
That's the barrier that goes
across.
And you see that that barrier
is 5.2 kJ/mole,
because they use -- they're
modern and they use joules,
whereas American organic
chemists tend to use
kilocalories.
But anyhow, if you multiply
that by 0.239,
you get it in kilocalories,
as what we've been talking
about,
which would say that the
barrier is 1.24 kcal/mol.
How big is the barrier in
ethane?
Does anybody remember from
before Thanksgiving?
Dana?
Student:  Three.
Prof: It's three. Right?
Just because they give a fancy
chart with numbers on it,
and just because it's been
calculated by some quantum
mechanical program that they got
access to and could use,
doesn't mean the numbers are
going to be right.
And they're not,
they're off by a factor of more
than two.
Right?
So don't believe everything you
see.
That's maybe the primary lesson
that this whole unit tells you.
Okay, it should be 2.9.
So let the buyer beware in
situations like that.
If you don't pay anything for
it, you probably get about that.
But the pictures are still very
nice, and the general shape is
correct.
So here's the rotation in
propane, and it says the barrier
is 5 kcal/mole.
And you know it's something
like 3.4,3.3,
instead.
Here's butane,
and again you can animate that
and see the various staggered
conformations and the fully
eclipsed one.
And we know the gauche is
supposed to be 0.9 kcal/mole;
which is not what this says.
And forget the scale on the
left.
We can use that 0.9 to tell how
much of the gauche there should
be at equilibrium.
And let's rehearse this again.
Remember, it's 10^(3/4^(
)ΔH),^( )in
kilocalories.
So 3/4ths^( )of 0.9 is 0.68.
So it means the ratio of gauche
to anti should be 1:4.7 (4.7 is
10^0.68).
Okay?
So 1:5, about.
But it depends on what you're
talking about,
because that gauche is in fact
chiral.
Let's see, I didn't have it
here.
Well you can -- I do it with my
hands.
Okay, so here's anti. Okay?
Here's gauche. Right?
But gauche is chiral.
It could also be this. Right?
It could be one hand,
or the other;
the mirror image.
It's like a propeller of
gauche.
Right?
So when I say gauche,
what do I mean?
Do I mean gauche+,
or do I mean gauche-,
or do I mean both of them,
taken together?
Because obviously,
if I include -- if I say gauche
and mean both of them -- right?
-- then I have to multiply this
by two, and the ratio is 1:2.4,
instead of 1:4.7.
Okay?
So there has to be this
statistical factor taken into
account as well,
when you use a collective name
like gauche.
Okay, the eclipsed is 3.4
kcal/mole.
That will tell how fast anti
goes to gauche.
So the difference in the well
heights,
tells how much gauche there is
at the equilibrium,
and the barrier height tells
how fast you go,
from one to the other.
So how fast do you go from anti
to gauche?
Do you remember how to do that?
Anybody remember?
Chenyu, do you remember how to
do it?
Student:  How to do what?
Prof: How to find out
how fast something is,
if you know how big the barrier
is you have to go across?
Student:  I'm not sure.
Prof: No,
but you'll know it for the
final.
Student:  I'm sure.
Prof: Okay?
It's (10^13th)/second;
pretty fast.
But then slowed down by that
same kind of equilibrium
constant, 10^(-3/4 of how big
the barrier is).
Now, if the barrier is 3.4 --
say it was four,
say the barrier's four;
it's about that.
10^3/4ths^( )of four is 10^3rd.
Right?
So it's slowed down by 10^3.
It's 10^13th/second times
10^-3.
Right?
So it's 10^10th per second.
Okay, there it is.
Oops, I did it wrong.
What did I do wrong here?
Student:  You said four
instead of 3/4ths.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  You made it
four instead of 3/4ths.
Prof: That's not the
difference though.
I think I've got a typo here.
That can happen.
Okay, anyhow,
I think -- subject to thinking
while I'm not on my feet -- that
this should be about 10^10th per
second.
Okay?
Anyhow, you see how you would
use it.
Right?
10^13th times -- whoops,
oh I forgot to plug;
no, I did plug it in.
Oh, it's okay.
Okay, so there we go. Okay?
And the fully eclipsed barrier
is about 4.4 kcal/mole.
But that's hard to access
experimentally.
Why?
Because experimentally you try
to tell how fast one thing goes
to another.
Right?
But it's possible to get from
anti to gauche without going
over that barrier,
and it's possible to go from
gauche to anti without going
over that barrier.
To go from gauche to gauche,
do you have -- notice that
360° is the same as 0°.
Right?
So you can go from this gauche
to this gauche,
by going over that barrier.
Right?
So can you measure that rate
and see what that barrier is?
No, because there's an easier
way to go.
Instead of going like this,
to get from one gauche to the
other, you just go like this.
Right?
So there's an easier way to do
it.
So you can't measure the rate
and know what that barrier is.
That barrier is more or less
irrelevant experimentally.
Okay, or here's the ring flip
in cyclohexane.
Now let me -- I'll use this one
to animate it,
to show you how.
You can try this program
yourself.
Okay, so here we go.
And there's the thing doing its
ring-flip.
And it's nice because you can
grab it and rotate it around and
see it from different points of
view as it does its ring-flip.
So there's flipping one end
down, and then flipping the
other end up,
to go from one chair to the
other.
So you can fiddle with this.
Or you can get models and try
them too.
Okay or, as I said,
you can go -- we could stop
that -- and you can go over here
and see what it looks like at
the halfway point.
Now notice that that is a
little bit like a boat.
But it's a twisted boat,
as I said, because the actual
boat is up here at the top.
In fact, even at the top it's
not -- oh, pardon me,
I said the wrong thing.
It's not -- up at the top,
it's sort of a half chair,
half boat.
Right?
This top left carbon is still
in the sort of chair-like form,
or these five carbons are.
But this one is halfway bent
up, toward a boat.
Okay?
Anyhow, you can fiddle with
those things.
Oh let's see -- what do I need
to do here?
Go back here. Okay.
So there's the chair conformer,
there's the flexible or
twisted-boat conformer.
Now that one is really fun.
I'm going to do it here,
and you people who have this
can do it.
Notice -- did you notice when
you played with this,
that the chair is sort of
rigid.
If you try to twist it,
it's hard.
Has everybody felt it,
to feel that?
But if you get into the boat
form, like that,
then it's quite flexible.
You can do this,
to your heart's content.
Did you feel that?
After you've passed it across,
pass it back so everybody can
feel how -- this is great,
like the orb.
Right?
But the chair is quite rigid.
And as it goes from chair to
boat, it clicks;
like click.
See it click?
Okay.
So there's a barrier;
that's the point.
But in the flexible form
there's not a barrier,
it just smoothly rotates.
Okay, so there's that barrier
of 11 kcal/mol.
So it takes some time to get
back and forth.
Okay, and here's the flexible
one, and you can animate that
and watch it flex.
Okay?
So that's the twist-boat form.
Okay, now we're going to talk
about the shape,
strain energy,
and molecular mechanics.
The point is to talk about
molecular mechanics.
How do you get these energies?
That particular animation used
a quantum mechanical
calculation.
It didn't do a very good job on
the energies,
as we just showed.
But is there an easier way to
get these energies?
And there is,
and it's called molecular
mechanics.
Essentially it's just using
Hooke's Law for the model,
to calculate strain energies.
So we already saw the torsional
energy of ethane at 3 kcal/mole
--
a threefold barrier,
three minima,
as you go across -- and the
conformational energy of butane.
And it's fun to remember those
numbers: 0.9 for anti to gauche;
3.4 barrier between them,
and then maybe 4.4,
but who knows,
for the other one.
Okay, now remember 1950 is when
all these things were happening.
So in 1946 there was a paper by
Frank Westheimer and Joseph
Mayer from the University of
Chicago,
about using mechanics to
calculate the energies of
conformations.
The particular thing they were
interested in is when you have
two benzene rings hooked
together, so that they can
rotate like this.
Right?
They can't rotate freely if you
have things here that are
sticking out,
that would run into one
another, as you tried to rotate
them.
Right?
So you could get one that's
twisted this way and one that's
twisted this way,
in a substituted biphenyl.
And you can resolve them,
and get optically active forms
--
one that's twisted to the
right, one that's twisted to the
left --
even though you don't have a
carbon that has four different
things on it;
because it can't rotate. Right?
But the question is,
how big should that barrier be?
And Westheimer,
in fact, is your great-uncle.
Right?
Because he also studied with
Conant and Kohler,
at Harvard;
the same as my teacher,
Bartlett, did.
Okay?
So he was interested in
physical-organic chemistry and
did this.
Incidentally,
he's also the guy that figured
out which hydrogen you pull off
on ethanol;
you know, that enzymes choose
between the pro-R and the
pro-S hydrogens.
So anyhow, Westheimer did this
in 1946 and figured if you have
a bromine here and a bromine
here,
that when it's flat,
and achiral,
that's the transition state
between being twisted one way
and being twisted the other;
that -- whoops,
sorry -- that these two things
would run into one another.
That would mean the bonds might
bend back a little bit or
something;
how much energy would that cost?
So he tried to do it by what's
called molecular mechanics.
So these programs calculate the
energy,
and they can minimize it by
adjusting angles to get the
minimum energy,
by treating these molecules as
if they were mechanical.
And to achieve useful precision
they require a very large set of
empirical force constants;
that is, how strong are the
various springs?
And you adjust these
arbitrarily on some test
molecules, in order to get the
best values, and then try to
apply it to something else.
You can also do it nowadays by
reliable -- unlike the ones we
just talked about -- quantum
mechanical calculations.
But I want to show you how many
parameters there are,
when you do molecular
mechanics.
Okay, so this is so-called MM2
-- that's a particular molecular
mechanics scheme -- and these
are parameters.
So there are sixty-six
different atom types;
fourteen different types of
carbon, depending on what it's
bonded to.
Okay, so here are some of --
here are the fourteen different
types of carbon.
The carbon in an alkane,
in an alkene,
in an alkyne.
That carbon in a carbon cation.
The carbon in a carbonyl group.
The carbon in a carboxylate;
and so on.
And these have different van
der Waals radii;
which is one of the things you
have to put in.
Okay?
Now, then you have these
various kinds of atoms hooked
together, and you have a certain
strength for stretching the
spring.
That is to say you need what
the equilibrium bond distance
is,
the minimum energy bond
distance, and how strong the
force constant is,
for stretching that spring.
So notice there are 138
different bond stretchings.
These are just the ones that
involve where the first atom is
of type one.
Okay?
So you need to find out what
all those force constants are.
Okay.
Then you can bend bonds,
and there are 624 different
strengths of springs for bending
different types of bonds.
Forty-one, shown here,
involve alkane carbon,
alkane carbon,
and then some other group;
it could be another alkane
carbon.
That's the very top one;
one, one one is three alkane
carbons.
So that's the force constant
for bending the bond.
But then there are different
equilibrium bond angles;
all close to 109.5 -- remember,
that's the tetrahedral angle --
but a little bit different,
according to whether that
particular carbon has two other
R groups on it,
or an R group and an H,
or two Hs, in addition to the
other two groups you're talking
about actually bending the bond.
So you get -- so there are --
so then, of course,
you can twist bonds also.
That's what conformation
involves, after all.
And there are 1494 different
bond-twisting,
and for each bond-twisting you
have three parameters here.
For example,
V3 -- also V2,
V1 -- for each of those 1500
whatever number it was of bonds.
I'll just show you what that
means.
V3 means a threefold barrier.
And it says its height is 0.093
kcal -- yeah,
kcal/mole.
So here it is. Right?
It's maximum when it's
eclipsed, it's minimum when it's
staggered, maximum eclipsed,
minimum staggered.
So that's a threefold barrier,
for rotating.
But there's also,
for a particular kind of set of
three bonds, there's a twofold
barrier, which looks like that.
Right?
And that one,
you see, is 0.27 kilocalories
high.
And there's also a one-fold
barrier, like that,
which is, for that particular
one, alkane, alkane,
alkane, alkane,
0.2 kilocalories high.
Now you add all these together,
and that is the torsional
contribution to the energy in
butane;
or anything where you have
alkane, alkane,
alkane, alkane.
Right?
Now we know what it really
looks like in butane.
It looks like that.
The scale is much bigger.
So this is a rather minor
contribution.
Now why is it that the anti is
the most stable,
according to this scheme?
It's because it's -- the van
der Waals repulsion is least
when these two carbons are as
far apart from one another,
rather than being eclipsed with
one another.
Right?
But that then is biased -- you
calculate that van der Waals
repulsion, which depends on the
radii of various things.
Right?
And you then tweak it by adding
this to it, as well.
Right?
So you can see that these are
pretty complicated -- I mean,
for a computer it's not a
problem.
It's a lot easier than quantum
mechanics, finding all these
curvatures and stuff.
But it's still a pretty
intricate thing and an enormous
numbers of parameters.
After simplification,
the so called MM3 scheme has
more than 2000 arbitrarily
adjustable parameters that you
have to fiddle out by knowing a
lot of different experimental
results.
And what would I have to make
the numbers to make that right?
And then it has to be also
right with this one,
this one, this one.
So obviously you need at least
2000 different molecules to
determine 2000 parameters,
or 2000 different measurements
at least.
So it's a very highly
parameterized system.
Contrast it with quantum
mechanics, where there are no
arbitrary parameters;
all you have is the particle
masses, their charges,
and Planck's constant.
Right?
So there's nothing
fundamentally correct about
molecular mechanics.
It's just a very complicated
scheme that's been tweaked to
try to give good results for the
molecules that it's tweaked on
the basis of.
But that doesn't necessarily
mean it'll work for anything
else.
But it does work pretty well.
And the nice thing about it is
by looking at the calculations,
you can figure out why
things happen the way they do.
For example,
here's ideal cyclohexane,
the way we've been drawing it.
And we can look at the various
kinds of strain that there are
in that.
First we take an ideal
cyclohexane;
which means it has ideal bond
lengths, bond angles,
and is staggered,
like this.
Okay?
And there's no strain for
stretch, bend,
or what's called stretch-bend.
Why is there a term called
stretch-bend?
Because when you stretch a bond
-- it might be easier to bend,
or conceivably harder to bend
when it's stretched.
So you have to put another term
in for that.
Okay, but there is torsional
energy, because there are gauche
interactions here,
like that one.
But there are six of them,
as you go around the ring.
So they're not anti.
So there's torsional energy.
And then there's what's called
"non-1,4 van der Waals
energy";
which in fact is favorable,
it's attractive.
Okay.
And here you see an example:
one, two, three four,
five, those atoms,
atom one and atom five there,
are five atoms apart.
Right?
So it's non-1,4; it's 1,5.
And they're at a distance where
their interaction is attractive,
according to van der Waals
energy.
But you can have 1,4 van der
Waals energy,
as here.
There's one, two, three four;
and that, you see,
costs you -- Its strain of 6.3
kcal/mol -- not that particular
one, but sum them all up.
Okay?
There's a very bad one here,
you can see,
between one and eight.
Those are rather close
together.
Okay?
So there's this much strain in
that.
Now, what a molecular mechanics
program can do is adjust the
geometry -- twist bonds,
stretch them,
bend them and so on -- to
minimize the energy.
Okay?
And here's what happens.
Whereas the total strain energy
before deformation is almost 8
kcal/mole, after -- let's see,
what did I do?
There.
After you've minimized it,
those are the energies.
It falls to 6.56.
So it gets a kilocalorie 0.3
better.
Okay?
Now notice what happened.
It stretched the bonds a little
bit.
It bent the bonds a little bit.
Right?
Let's see exactly what it did,
by looking at the model.
So there's the -- it's going to
stretch and flatten the ring
slightly, to reduce that bad van
der Waals repulsion.
Notice the 1,4 van der Waals
before was 6.32,
and it's cut down to 4.68.
So watch what happens.
So this is -- did you see it?
Let's back up.
See, it flattens and stretches,
just a bit, to get -- to reduce
those van der Waals repulsions.
So this way I told you to draw
cyclohexane, to get it the same
way Mohr did,
is the way organic chemists do
it.
But it's not quite right.
Actually the rings flatten a
little bit and the things that
should be axial spread out just
a little bit.
Okay, fine, so some things get
better, some things get worse;
overall it gets a little better.
And it would be very hard to do
that in your head.
Right?
Molecular mechanics is good to
do that.
Okay, now there you notice is a
gauche butane within the
cyclohexane.
And we know how much gauche
butane costs,
compared to anti butane.
How much strain is there in
gauche butane?
Remember gauche versus anti,
I said that was worth
remembering.
It's 0.9 kcal/mol.
Okay, but in fact,
in the whole thing,
there are six gauche butanes,
because every bond is part of a
gauche -- is the central bond of
a gauche butane.
So if you had six gauche
butanes, that would be a strain
of six times 0.9;
5.4 kcal/mol. Okay?
And in fact that's rather close
to 6.56.
So that actually is way
over-simplified.
But it's a good mnemonic device
for remembering how big it is.
It's about six gauche butanes.
Or suppose you had axial
methylcyclohexane.
Now you have much,
much worse van der Waals
interactions -- right?
-- 6 and 8 kcal/mol of strain.
But what's going to happen if I
let it relax,
if I run molecular mechanics
and let it minimize its energy?
Can you guess what's going to
happen?
How will the structure change?
Virginia?
Student:  The last
methyl group.
Prof: Yeah,
that methyl group on the top is
really in trouble -- right?
-- because of those non-1,4 van
der Waals repulsion.
But if you bend it back to the
right a little bit,
you'll reduce that.
So here's what happens,
it relaxes like that.
And now notice that the non-1,4
van der Waals went from being
bad, by 6 kcal/mol,
to being good by 1.3,
overall, summing them all up.
Right?
So it went from sixteen
kilocalories of strain to only
nine, or from seventeen to nine.
Okay.
And notice that here there are
two more gauche butanes,
in axial methylcyclohexane.
There were already six in the
cyclohexane ring.
Now there are two more.
So you'd guess -- whoops I went
too fast -- you'd guess eight
times 0.9; 7.2.
It's 8.6.
It's in the right ballpark.
So it's roughly what you'd
expect for eight gauche butanes.
Okay?
Now, if you go from axial to
equatorial, then it turns out
that energy difference is 1.8
kcal/mole.
Equatorial is 1.8 better than
axial.
Does that surprise you,
that it's 1.8?
Could you have guessed that it
would be 1.8?
Notice when it was axial,
there were two gauche butane
interactions.
When it's equatorial,
those two gauche butanes become
anti butanes.
And a gauche to anti is 0.9.
There are two of them.
So 1.8. Right?
Two gauches become two antis.
So that's axial to equatorial.
And, in fact,
you could put other groups
there.
Like instead of methyl group,
it could be chlorine or bromine
or ethyl or something like that.
And for any of these,
if you can measure the amount
of equatorial and axial,
you can get a measure of how
big that group is.
Right?
So that, these so-called A
values,
the difference between energy
when it's axial and when it's
equatorial,
is a nice rough measure of the
effective group size.
So we'll stop here,
for now, and continue next
time.